alright
[Music]
hello how's hello to the award
with the most outstanding headlines of the
day nevada joins other
western states to reopen responsibly
this includes california oregon and
washington colorado just joined
the governor exists alone said the
States will share
important information and best practices on
how to prevent the spread of the virus and
reopen
responsibly Governors said their
decisions will be based on science,
not politics Governor has no
plans yet to reopen Won't
soon Congress approved  a coronavirus relief program
nevada senators say some of the money is
included for testing in our state
nevada will receive more than $7
million for testing and tracing of kobe
nineteen governor will only purchase
even more tests before taking decision
decision to reopen the company and now
you can use food stamps
to pay  for orders made online or
to pick up at supermarkets month the
company is also agreeing by
avoiding charging the extra charge for purchase
this will help people buy what
they need while maintaining
social distancing this option is
available in more than 70 stores and now
with your weather forecast there will be a lot of
sun and heat the temperatures will be in
the high 90s today it is important to
drink a lot of water take care of our
pets children and adults
i am sal and jaramillo and this was vince
neil in spanish
[Music]